- In these socially distance times,
we're always coming up with new ways
to connect with friends.
One way to make sure we
stay at least six feet apart
is to chat car to car.
That's why we created our
DRIVE-INTERVIEW, get it?
♪ DRIVE-INTERVIEW ♪
Recently I had a chance, he got it.
Recently I had a chance to catch up with
all around great guy, Jay Leno.
I love him so much and
I got to check out a,
do an interview with him from
his car, so check it out.
(upbeat music)
(car engine roars)
- Hey lady.
- Hey, what's up?
- Hi doll, how you doing?
I like that Buick, how are ya?
- Fancy meeting you here.
- Yeah, there you go.
- I liked your car,
what kinda car is that?
- This is a 1970 Dodge Challenger.
When I was a kid, this
is a car I always wanted
and now I got it.
And I'm with the girl I always
wanted, so now I got it.
So I've been doing them both for 50 years,
well I'm doing them both.
That sounds terrible, doesn't it?
(Kelly laughs)
That sounds bad,
but you know what I mean?
- Sounds bad, sounds perfect.
- You know what I mean?
- Do you like my beauty?
- That is very nice.
- Yeah.
- That's a beautiful car.
- It's Willie Nelson, blue
eyes crying in the rain.
- I like that era more.
- Yeah I know, I'm with you.
Did you grow up in drive-ins?
I actually grew up around drive-in.
- I did grow up around
drive-ins my first date,
I remember the movie I saw was 1966,
the movie with The Sand Pebbles
and I took this girl, I
was trying to be very cool.
You know, I remember I got some hamburgers
and the hamburger and ketchup
would come in with little packets.
- Yeah.
- So I'd reach and I do this,
you shake to get the
ketchup at the bottom.
- Yeah.
- So I'm doing that, and I
open it, I put on my burger,
very swat.
I throw that back in the bag.
So I'm talking to her,
I get the other Hamburg,
I reached out and I got another
ketchup packet, I do this.
Meanwhile, I see her I go, "Ou, ou!"
I go, "What!"
What I had done was I picked up the bottom
of the one I just opened,
as I was doing this,
I was throwing ketchup all over her face
and she's like, "Stop doing that,
"why are you throwing Ketchup?"
I go, "What!"
- And it's red, so that's awesome.
- Yeah, that was pretty
much the end of the day.
- It probably stained everything.
I love drive-ins by the way.
But did you ever have road rage?
Like have you ever had road rage
since you're in cars all the time?
- You know something,
I am a pretty calm guy.
And one day, this actually
happened down here.
I was on the Tonight
Show and I was somewhere
and a guy behind me.
I'm like, oh, so I pull
off and I go, "Go ahead."
And as he goes by, he gives me the finger.
So I wouldn't let it go and
what was that all about?
I tried, but he doesn't again.
So now I'm really mad and I can
size up people pretty quick.
So I look on him I go, let me guess,
mid fifties, bald, divorce, fat.
Your kids hate you, your wife hates you.
You got a dead end job.
- Oh my God I love you.
- Your going nowhere.
Your greatest day was in
high school, am I right?
(indistinct)
Okay, and now the guy starts crying.
- Oh no.
- So I'm like, "Well, I didn't mean."
He goes
I go look, so when I got out
of my car, I get in his car
and I go like, I'm
sorry, I didn't mean it.
He goes, "No, everything
you said was right.
"You hit it right."
I realized I had just nailed the guy.
So I said, "Well, you have a kid?"
" Yes I have."
I said, "Do you have a daughter?"
and he goes, "Yes."
I said, "Tailor Swift
is on the show Thursday.
"I'll leave some tickets,
you bring your daughter,
"I'll introduce you to
daughter to Tailor Swift."
Okay, so the guy comes
and he brings his daughter
and he meets her.
And we, and it turned
out actually very good.
But it was one of those things where,
as a comedian, when you're
dealing with hecklers,
you can size up people pretty quick.
- Yeah.
- And I just said, fat,
bald, dead end job,
divorced.
- Divorced.
- And he went, it was right on.
(both laughing)
I was right on, I mean, I'm not that mean,
but it was right on every count.
- You're almost exaggerating
and this happened.
- Exactly.
- That so nice though, what you did.
- But it was funny, it was funny.
- This is amazing, you're an optimist.
- I'm an optimist,
that's why.
- You are.
So I had so much fun on Jay's Garage.
- Yeah you did great,
people liked that a lot.
We've got a lot of good reaction to it.
- What's up in the new season?
- Well, actually we just signed today
to start our new season.
So,
- Oh right on.
- We got a lot of celebrities lined up.
I just can't say who just yet but--
- Yeah.
- It's just fun, it's just a silly show
about people in cars
and doing dumb things.
- I love it, yeah.
You've also got something else though.
Is it you're hosting the new
version of You Bet Your Life?
- Yeah, that's still like
eight, nine months away.
But yeah, that'll be fun.
My favorite thing when I was doing
the Tonight Show with Jay Walker,
we just went out and pick people at random
and ask them questions.
- Yeah.
- And I was always astounded,
you couldn't write...
I mean, my favorite question was,
and this is an actual question.
How was Mount Rushmore formed?
You know the most common answer?
- What?
- Erosion.
- No they did it.
- Yes, I would say six out
of 10 people said erosion,
like the wind, the rain
picked not four presidents
but four of our greatest presidents,
just pounding the side of a mountain.
Unbelievable.
- Wow!
- I mean, if you wrote
that, people would say,
oh no, there's no one who'd ever say that,
but they did say that.
And that's what made it
fun, when you catch people.
- Or scary, fun or scary.
- Yeah, or scary, yeah.
- Who's out there?
- I like to go with fun.
- Okay, yeah you're the optimist,
- Exactly.
I'll be the realist.
(Kelly laughs)
Exactly.
All right, well oh my gosh.
I love seeing you here.
- It's good seeing you.
- This is so awesome, next time we'll be,
I'll be on your show again
and we'll be on another car.
- Let's do it all right, babe.
- Okay, bye!
- See you later.
- Sounds good.
(upbeat music)